welcome to this video playing our st
from the Ukrainian Ukraine yes for once
I get it right okay the French defence
and let's play the classical down stairs
so called style its variation here like
has multiple moves a six Queen B 6
Bishop e7 all kinds of stuff and
experiment a bit this move as son
virtually unknown it can often transpose
to Bishop e7 and I think it actually did
transpose not okay let's see what
happens one idea is now to play a five
after oh he's replying very quickly
after taking Knight f6 I have chances to
go to to e4 but the seam prevented see
playing for g4 probably
yeah maybe let's play this first it
looks a bit mysterious I know it's
looking at the the deep on that my idea
is to to do the following you'll see
what I'm getting at want to play night
to e4 and then the bishop is actually
not so bad here okay how to play now I
can I can play some improving moves
first 94 it's not necessary right away
what about what about trying for Bishop
to a 6 let's try that Bishop a 60 this
is a very direct approach
yeah interesting however if I go pick up
a six now how does he play now I mean am
I not getting a blockade on their five
with a piece if the bishops are off he
has a hard time to attach f5 okay
doesn't mind should I play g6 mm-hmm
it's not really helping me much g6 take
let's let's do this first get rid of
this this Bishop then wandering Knight
if form
yeah it shouldn't be too bad this kind
of position yeah I thought I'm I have
enough counter play here with Bishop c5
and the C file I hope that's true like
f5 text takes rook c8 Quincy to coming
maybe it down is too slow on this as
possible it takes here
mm maybe create but wait if i go here
intending quincy to if it takes six i
can just play Queenie's a blank and
capture it next move this isn't a
problem it seems he wants to go to g5
that how dangerous is this really or if
all is a drug see one he wants supply mm
not sure yeah but i think i should have
enough play here also cleaned III if
everything else fails i know he's going
for that interesting he's seven is the
issue here
hmm
greenbee two is seven now this is hard
to survive
okay I probably need to get the Queen's
off it's not especially great but don't
see what else there is some counter play
with Roxy to
I think I'll get the e6 phone died
afraid to attack you this isn't so bad
even maybe I'm quite okay
and yeah I'm not in bad shape here the
look on the seventh I probably worried a
bit too much so I give up this
you cannot play age for this is why I
could could do that
and I will move from Jack no I'm going
here yeah like it's just better maybe
maybe a draw but cannot I cannot lose
I'm position at least game yeah nice
fair play can you can try to overdraw at
least of course it's it's a dead ROI you
get to get two points and we have rook
against rook yeah surprise I mean I
really thought I what was in some
trouble but maybe maybe this was okay
yeah what the computer wants take okay
dad this is a much better version yeah
the comp is usually very precise in this
kind of positions instead of taking here
it wants to take here after which I need
to take with the rook then he takes
takes e7 rookie aide only move or only
send someone with fruit d 1 is same
route d3 and this is I'm just clearly
better for why probably it's it's
winning probably yeah it seeks appointed
to protected paso the only thing is
black quickly gets to block it and maybe
has some counter play on one of the
files but it's upon a very big bone so
probably winning in the game he allowed
a much more counter play yeah here I'm
just much quicker now with him this is
this is better for black really in
surprisingly I wasn't really a who
wasn't really aware and
probably somewhere around here i can i
can improve but quite often the drawing
margin is pretty big in this kind of
endgame yeah i hear ya the comp wants to
take on g5 oops here just probably
better out this is gone anyway and I'm
I'm keeping the King back on the
second-ranked blocking it this is a bit
better hmm is it still a draw yeah
probably should should be it should be
still a drop by this yes of course white
can get the ape on stupid yeah you can
play him a form and you will get the a
pond and then it's really a draw ok yeah
interesting game thanks for watching